I want to make a quick correction to the
video on quasars in that video I said
and I mistakenly said that the quasars
or that the chrétien disk that's really
forming that or releasing the energy of
the quasar that's releasing energy
predominantly in the in the x-ray part
of the electromagnetic spectrum and that
was incorrect most quasars are actually
emitting electromagnetic creation across
the spectrum all the way from x-rays all
the way from x-rays as high frequency as
x-rays all the way down to infrared all
the way down to para infrared and some
quasars even release super high
frequency gamma rays and they'll release
low-frequency electromagnetic waves all
the way down to radio waves so I just
wanted to make that correction it's not
predominantly in the x-ray part of the
spectrum it's across the spectrum right
over here it's this entire range of the
spectrum and sometimes even a wider
range now the other thing I want to
clarify is this is the range of the
spectrum that's being emitted but we
have to remember that most or actually
all of these collisions are quite far
away the closest is 780 million
light-years away
many of them are many many billions of
light-years away and so they're moving
away from us at a very fast speed or
because they're getting red shifted
because the universe is expanding so
fast relative to us at that point or
that coordinate is moving so fast away
from our coordinate and so even though
this is the spectrum that's being
emitted it's all going to be redshifted
it's all going to be red shifted down
and so we are going to observe things at
a much at a much lower frequency maybe
around the radio part of the frequency
so everything will be red shifted down
and that's why these were originally
called quasi-stellar radio sources
anyway hopefully that clears things up a
little bit